president-elect joe biden is pushing it
with plans to activate the defense
production act and ramp up the national
supply of the coronavirus vaccine
the moment uh he takes office next week
mr biden is planning to set up new
vaccination sites and make sure 100
million shots are administered
during his first 100 days in office
senior white house correspondent ouija
jang is with the president-elect in
wilmington
delaware wiege good morning to you
good morning jeff and good morning to
everybody this weekend the
president-elect will put the finishing
touches
on his inaugural address which he hopes
will be a moment to unite the country
but you're right all week he has focused
on the twin crises trying to restore
a ravaged economy and control the
coronavirus by vaccinating as many
people
as possible truthfully
we remain in a very dark winter
infection rates are up 34
president-elect joe biden did not
downplay the state of the pandemic
as he unveiled a plan to fulfill his
promise of 100 million vaccine shots in
100 days
this would be one of the most
challenging operational efforts ever
undertaken by our country
but you have my word and we will manage
the hell
out of this operation mr biden is
calling on fema to mobilize
thousands of staff members to create
more vaccination sites
use the defense production act to
increase supplies
and train 100 000 new workers to
administer the shots
he also plans to launch a public
education campaign to inform
people about vaccine safety our
administration will lead with science
and sciences
the president-elect even elevated the
head of the office of technology and
science to a cabinet-level position
filled by eric lander who helped map the
human genome
mr biden has long said the coronavirus
crisis
is intertwined with the economic
emergency
this week he also released a 1.9
trillion dollar relief package he's
urging lawmakers to pass
more than half of the funds would
provide direct relief
with fourteen hundred dollar stimulus
checks an increase in
unemployment insurance from three
hundred to four hundred dollars a week
and a higher child tax credit mr biden
is also pushing to increase minimum wage
to 15 dollars an hour
he's trying to find republican support
for the huge price tag
but that did not stop the
president-elect from calling
some of them out it was shocking
to see members of the congress while the
capital was under siege
by a deadly mob of thugs refused to wear
a mask while they were in secure
locations
what the hell hell's the matter with
that
it's time to grow up
president-elect biden's chief of staff
said he and senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell are in frequent contact
through
straightforward and polite conversations
looking ahead to inauguration
mr biden said he feels safe attending on
wednesday based on the
intelligence he's received so far dana
all right weeja thank you